und das hier ist Ian der Monster
Hurrikan das hier das ist das Auge des
Wirbelsturms und zwar von oben
aufgenommen aus dem Weltall über 200
Kilometer groß und es zeigt diese
brachiale Brutalität des Hurrikans
Windgeschwindigkeit von mehr als 250
km/h sind drin und celige Blitze sind
hier zu sehen Kategorie 3 von 5 ihren
hat Kuba bereits schwer verwüstet das
komplette Land ist ohne Strom zerstörte
Häuser entwurzelte Bäume überschwemmte
Gebiete Menschen auf der Flucht und
jetzt steuert der Hurrikan Florida an
die Westküste die Warnung hier ein
lebensbedrohlicher Sturm meine Sturmflut
Meter hohe Wellen werden erwartet die
Menschen in Angst breiten sich vor so
gut es eben geht im Supermarkt lange
Schlangen an den Kassen leere Regale wie
wir hier bereits sehen im Baumarkt genau
das gleiche Bild
die Häuser werden für brettert seit rund
100 Jahren soll es nicht mehr einen
solchen Hurrikan gegeben haben
und dann gibt es noch diese Menschen
hier die auf diese Welle aufspringen
Surfer am Strand von Florida freuen sich
über die Wellen die der Wirbelsturm vor
sich herschiebt
und während alles reißausnimmt
fliegen sie hier mitten in das Auge des
Wirbelsturms wir sehen hier noch Bilder
aus
Florida aus Kuba die Zerstörung hier
auch noch mal der Livestream wie sich
der Wirbelsturm hier vor wenigen Stunden
von Kuba jetzt auf die Westküste der USA
fortbewegt in wenigen Stunden soll es
dann soweit sein mit
Windgeschwindigkeiten von mehr als
215 km/h
wir schalten jetzt nach Tampa in Florida
zu unserem us-stromreporter Herbert
Bauer Nebel Herbert du stehst an der
Küste vom Golf von Mexiko es findet
bereits bei dir hier soll der Hurrikan
ihren voll auf Land treffen wie groß ist
die Sorge in der Nacht bei den Menschen
jetzt
es wird erwartet dass der Sturm in
ungefähr 12 Stunden gegen die Küste
krachen wird und zwar wesentlich weiter
südlich als zuerst angenommen wurde
zuerst dachte man hier in Tampa wäre der
Ground Zero dieser möglichen Hurrican
Katastrophe jetzt hat der Sturm seine
Bahn geändert und wird aufschlagen
wahrscheinlich nördlich von Fort Myers
das sind ungefähr 150 bis 200 km südlich
von hier das ist natürlich eine kleine
entleichterung hier für Tampa wo sich
die Menschen vorbereitet haben wie
gesagt den ganzen Tag
Sandsäcke aufgeht aufgestürmt haben
Geschäfte vernagelt haben viele Menschen
sind geflüchtet es gab Staus auf den
Autobahnen wirklich dramatische Szenen
dass alles hat sich jetzt nach Süden
verlagert und es wird hier wirklich ein
eine schwere Hurricane erwartet
möglicherweise sogar die Kategorie 4 das
wäre die zweit höchste Kategorie mit
Winden von bis zu 200 Stundenkilometern
und natürlich einer gewaltigen Sturmflut
die das eben die Wassermenge die ein
solcher Hurrikan vor sich herschiebt die
dann zu Überschwemmungen führt und bei
diesen Überschwemmungen kommen die
meisten Menschen bei Hurricanes ums
Leben und vor dieser Sturmflut haben die
Behörden hier auch gewarnt es gibt sogar
Berechnungen bereits dass das einer der
teuersten Stürme Wirbelstürme in der
US-Geschichte werden könnte mit Schäden
von bis zu 45 Milliarden Dollar das
einzige Glück was man hier ist Orten
kann ist die Tatsache dass der Sturm
wesentlich schneller über Florida
hinüberziehen wird als bisher angenommen
er sollte bereits am
Mittwochabend die die Mitte von Florida
erreichen und dann eben in den entlang
in den Atlantik hinaus ziehen warum ist
er gerade so bedrohlich so gefährlich
einerseits ist es die Stärke des Sturmes
Kategorie 4 wie gesagt das sind Winde
bis zu 200 Stundenkilometer dazu kommt
die Größe des Sturmes es gibt
Wirbelstürme die sind sehr kleiner und
kompakt die ziehen dann eine Schneise
der Verwüstung zwar aber die aus der
Ausmaß der Schäden ist nicht so weit
verbreitet bei riesen stürmen wie eben
Ehren ist es einfach eine riesige Fläche
die betroffen ist von diesen stürmen
betroffen das heißt in diesem Fall
umgestürzte Bäume umgestürzte Strom am
meisten
abgedeckte Häuser überschwemmte Häuser
wirkliche Schäden und natürlich mitten
drinnen die Menschen die Zuflucht
gesucht haben entweder entweder in ihren
eigenen Häusern oder in
zufluchtstädten und die sind natürlich
teilweise in Lebensgefahr wenn sie sich
nach draußen begeben der Monster
Hurrikan Ian live dazu aus Florida unser
Bild Reporter Herbert Bauer Nebel danke
dir für den Moment
[Musik]